today's game is an exciting evans gambit
played between
stockfish and leela in the chess.com
computer chess
championship specifically this game was
played in the eco mega match which
featured only stockfish and lila
playing over 2 000 games in some of the
most exciting
theoretical opening positions now the
evans gambit opens with pawn to e4
and then e5 knight f3 knight c6
bishop c4 bishop c5 and pawn to b4
this move is the starting position of
the evans gamut
now cowards may retreat and not accept
the gambit but of course
in this exciting game we do get the
acceptance of the evans gambit bishop
takes b4
white's idea is pawn c3 and then
expanding in the center
getting rapid development and open lines
to compensate for the sacrifice
pawn now the bishop needs to retreat and
the most common retreat is bishop a5 as
played and now wherever the bishop
retreats whether to a5 or a different
square you should pretty much
always play pawn to d4 and after a
capture
you should castle so this happens now
in this position the move pawn takes c3
is played
and this is the end of book for this
particular uh
game it means that the engines are
forced to play through this position
lila would not have played the greediest
and most exciting move
pawn takes c3 if it was entirely lila's
choice
both engines agree that white is now a
little bit better after this move
and in practice white scores really
really well black isn't lost
but black is struggling so what would be
better
if you had full choice well the most
popular move here
is pawn to d6 now this move is one
that is really unclear both players get
their share of wins and losses here
really exciting stuff
now maybe the best move is the third
most popular move knight g to e7 and
here
black significantly outscores white so
if you get this position
maybe play knight g to e7 but in this
game
we're looking at pawn take c3 now
stockfish plays queen b3 tickling this
pawn right here
and that pawn needs to be defended queen
f6 good move but of course
the queen can be a target when it
develops early so bishop g5
the queen needs to move and also defend
this pawn so queen g6
and knight take c3 this captures of
course the pawn on c3 and
probably more importantly it develops
the knight
now the next move by leela is maybe one
that might surprise humans a little bit
it is bishop takes c3 you're giving up
your dark squared bishop here for the
knight but
of course you're also down in
development and you want to get some
pieces off the board especially some of
the active pieces that might attack you
for example if knight g to e7 developing
getting ready to castle
knight d5 is a dangerous idea from white
here
leaping in and if you trade here on d5
then white has the ability to open the e
file
this can recall a famous game uh fischer
versus fine where bobby fischer won
in 18 moves so you don't want to lose in
moves and neither does leela so lila
trades off the knight on c3
queen takes c3 and if knight f6 then
pawn e5 is a little bit dangerous
so leela tries knight g to e7 getting
ready to castle and just get
out of danger as much as possible so now
bishop takes
e7 giving up the dark squared bishop and
allowing more trades when you've already
sacrificed
two pawns in this position but if knight
takes e7 then knight e5 is a fork
hitting the queen and also hitting the
pawn on f7 and white has a winning
attack here
so the king needs to recapture king
takes e7
now the king is obviously not happy to
be on e7 but
also white did just trade off the dark
squared bishop that would be
probably the most important minor piece
to help get at this king on e7
so it's not like white is going to force
mate anytime soon
black is able to get the king out of the
center of the board
but that costs time and there's a lot of
pieces that need development
the next move i think is a really good
one and i'm going to try to highlight
as many of the building moves as
possible that stockfish plays
the great attacking master spielman once
said of
al jaekin that he can find the same
combinations as al yakin but he can't
get the same position
so pay a lot of attention to how
stockfish builds up this position
and eventually gets a combination
stockfish starts with pawn e5
great move this move helps get some
control of the dark squares and makes
moves like d6
much harder to achieve which means that
developing these pieces
is also very difficult rook e8 of course
very natural developing the rook to the
only half open file available to black
and the king is getting ready to pull
back here to f8 rook
ae1 i like this move a lot i also think
this is really instructive the two rooks
are placed in the center
now in the game they're going to double
on the e file which of course makes
sense
but i think there are also some lines
where you can imagine this knight moving
and then the pawns rolling like this
and they could be very very effective
here i think a lot of humans wouldn't
play rook ae1 because it kind of locks
in this rook here on
f1 but you can see stockfish likes the
move
so the king now steps back king f8 and
bishop d3 hitting the queen and of
course the queen doesn't want to give up
the pawn on h7
so queen h6 now another nice instructive
attacking move
rook e4 this move threatens rook h4
which will hit the queen and also hit
the pawn on h7
so there's an immediate idea to win
material and we have a bit of
a bit of a crisis here for black now
at this point stockfish thinks that the
best move
is pawn to f5 now a human
probably doesn't want to play a move
like this that opens up a lot of squares
against your king and also really
softens the light squares
but it does seem to be the last good try
for black after pawn f5 of course
you could consider rook h4 which is very
tempting dangerous and
might even be the best move but
stockfish's best line
the one that it thought was best at
least when it was playing the game
is pawn takes f6 opening more lines it
makes a lot of sense of course
now after rook takes e4 bishop takes e4
queen takes
f6 offering a queen trade of course you
don't want to trade queens you want to
keep the queens on the board and try to
attack
black needs to defend this h7 pawn so
pawn h6
and stockfish's best move is pawn to h3
not a very human move but there we go
and now you really need to develop so
pawn d5
and then after pawn d5 you have queen
takes d5 and you go for a queen trade
with queen e6
and stockfish thinks this is a little
better for white
so this is a long and complicated line
but at least it doesn't seem like
there's a forced win for white
instead leela played the move pawn to g6
accepting a very very passive position
and immediately stockfish goes from
thinking hey maybe i'm a little better
to
hey i think i'm a lot better and i might
be winning
so after pawn g6 stockfish continues
with
rook fe1 here i love bringing out the
rook the last piece that wasn't
contributing
the queen pulls back to g7 she feels
very buried here but there's an
immediate idea of pawn d6
to try to make some exchanges and
utilize this pin right here which is why
stockfish pulls back
and doesn't allow that with queen c1 if
pawn d6 had been played
then there was pawn takes d6 and after a
trade on e4
the bishop recaptures and this is a
problem and this is a problem and
white's position
is just overwhelming so after queen c1
we see king over to g8 doesn't really
accomplish anything but it's very hard
to accomplish
anything pawn h4 another great
instructive move that helps build the
attack
you have the idea of pawn h5 and maybe
even pawn h6
and these moves are often utilized by
neural network engines to really clamp
in
on the opponent's position and provoke
weaknesses pawn h6 trying to make sure
that
you know this pawn doesn't get to h6 and
lines are not opened
so you're getting ready to meet pawn h5
with
pawn to g5 for black now
i think this is maybe the best attacking
move in the game rook
1 to e3 this rook suddenly lifts and it
doesn't seem like it should have
any potential here along the third rank
but as we will see in the game it
definitely does have potential
in this position it seems like there's
only one move that might not be losing
that's king f8 which is stockfish's
preference
and it definitely thinks it's much much
better here which of course makes sense
black can barely move anything in this
position and king f8
may avoid some of the immediate threat
threats in the position
but it certainly doesn't give black a
desirable position however
there's at least no clear forced wind
that stockfish saw
after king f8 instead though king
h8 is pl is played here now pawn to h5
and the idea of taking here and opening
things is really unbearable
so we see pawn g5 which again was the
point of pawn h6
trying to keep things closed and now
knight takes g5 absolutely brilliant
from stockfish and
definitely winning it's only now that
lilo realizes
it's much much worse stockfish is saying
hey
i'm i'm basically winning here and
leela's going oh i'm definitely worse
in this position now after knight takes
g5 you can capture with the queen
or the pawn both are losing i'm not
going to dive
too deep into all of the possibilities
after queen takes g5
but here's the basic idea queen c3
threatening pawn e6 so that pawn needs
to be stopped
with rook e6 but then rook g3 hitting
the queen which can go back to a few
different squares
and after queen e7 you can double here
this is very strong
and you're soon going to follow up with
the idea of bishop b1
and then queen c2 or queen d3 making a
battery
total control of the g file total
control of the light squared diagonal
and it's just overwhelming
there's no way to defend against all the
threats that white quickly sets up
so in the game after knight takes g5 we
see
h takes g5 and pawn to h6
of course the queen cannot capture
because rook h3
pins and wins the queen right here so
after h6 we see queen back to f8
rook g3 just getting ready to go go over
and win the g5 pawn
and finish off your crushing attack here
an interesting move is pawn
f5 when we can capture on passant and
after rook takes e4
this move is good and should win but the
strongest move is queen takes g5
and here queen g7 check making
a pass pawn on the seventh rank and
forcing it through in multiple different
ways
is absolutely crushing so a beautiful
position here that would have been
completely overwhelming in the game
after rook g3 we see
knight takes e5 here and now queen takes
g5 and pawn f5 hitting this rook right
here
in this position leela was expecting
rook takes e5 when white is a lot better
but maybe white is not winning instead
though
stockfish played rook h4 and it's
only after rook h4 is on the board that
lila goes from thinking
oh this is a bad position but not
necessarily lost
to leela's acknowledging oh i am
definitely lost and again
stockfish has been thinking that lila is
definitely lost for a while
it clearly calculated better in this
line with rook
h4 so this move threatens queen g7 check
even a move like rookie 7 to add defense
to the g7
square doesn't really help because you
still go queen g7
check and uh if uh if rook takes g7 here
pawn takes g7 with double check you get
a check from both the rook
and the pawn and the only way to get out
of double check is to move the king
here we have king g8 and then there's
rook h8 your next turn is to capture
and promote a queen with check and
obviously you're completely winning here
with the white pieces
so the only try here and evidently what
lilam has calculated
is knight g4 and the idea here is of
course rookie one check
and also just to clog the g file which
is the basis of white's attack
but after knight g4 stockfish just
clears things out
rick h takes g4 and now pawn takes g4
and you might be thinking about
capturing this pawn right here that's
enough compensation for being a full
rook down but it does not win the game
instead the critical move is rook e3
this move just threatens rook takes e8
and then queen to g7 and checkmate so
this is a huge problem
and there's really no defense you can
also consider rook d8 here
and then just rookie 7 threatening rook
h7 mate
among other things there's no defense
after rookie 3 we do see rook takes e3
and now queen takes e3 black is up a
full rook here although of course
these pieces are completely out of the
game so it's hard to count them as full
pieces
this position is simply winning because
there's no way to stop
a check on the dark square diagonal here
and then after the king moves over
you simply have h7 check and then h8
equals queen
so in this position with all of the
extra material and the ability to make
the move in this position
there's no way for leela to save the
game white simply
executes the idea pawn d6 is played
queen d4
check king g8 h7 check of course the
bishop is defending
and then king over and we make our
protected queen
from here of course it's just a simple
a process to checkmate but in the
computer chess championship
we do play out to checkmate so this is
how the game concludes
of course the technique is always nice
and the queen and bishop work
perfectly well together in finishing the
game off
so final position here
sees the queen come into d7 and
checkmate
so i hope you've enjoyed this great game
and i hope it inspires some of you to
play
more evan's gambits the chess world
needs more evan's gambits
if you're interested in seeing more
great computer chess games then
a watch the computer chess championship
at chess.com
ccc but b also check out the playlist
that's popping up with lots of great
computer chess games that we've analyzed
on this channel
you can't find most of them anywhere
else